President Trump is riding high on an
impeachment approval rating bump but the
administration isn't resting on its
laurels from the campaign to the DOJ to
foreign policy Trump is getting more
aggressive not less he's getting more
aggressive in taking on his adversaries
demonstrating an eternal political truth
if you come at the King you best not
miss we will examine what comes next for
the instigators of the failed
impeachment coup then a methodist church
places Jesus Mary and Joseph in cages in
the crash merriam-webster goes full
leftist in its word of the year and the
New York Times brings us the dumbest
article on the internet today as always
all that and more i'm michael knowles
and this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
President Trump is riding high this
impeachment thing has not worked out
very well for Democrats how do I know it
because of the latest Quinnipiac poll
this is important for a couple reasons
one it's important because of the
numbers it's showing it's showing that
President Trump has got a pretty high
approval rating and it shows that
opposition to his impeachment and
removal from office is now at 51% the
majority of the country does not want
him impeached and removed from office
that's the highest number since
September what happened what started to
happen in September you had the
impeachment hearings and the impeachment
inquiry so before the impeachment
inquiry and impeachment hearings a lot
of Americans wanted president Trump
impeached didn't remove from office
afterward it didn't help the Democrats
it ended up helping the president it's
important for that reason it's also
important because of who did the poll
all right there are some polling firms
that tend to lean a little bit more
Republican they paint rosier numbers for
conservatives one of those would be
Rasmussen for instance which by the way
doesn't mean that Rasmussen is wrong or
a bad polling firm it just means that
generally if favors Republicans more
than other polls all of which skew
Democrat Quinnipiac is a left-leaning
poll and even the left-leaning poll
shows that now the majority of Americans
after this whole charade
after Adam Schiff and Jerry Nadler and
all these guys totally flopped in the
impeachment hearing the majority of
Americans opposed impeaching and
removing the president and it's not just
a three-month impeachment attempt okay
when we talk about impeachment we're not
just talking about this latest Ukraine
thing that started to explode in August
we're talking about a three-year
impeachment attempt this isn't the first
time they tried to get him they try
actually tried to get him and right
after he got elected and even before he
was sworn into office Democratic
senators made moves to try to to impeach
him or to set the stage for impeachment
then after that Al Green the congressman
not the musician came out and filed an
impeachment resolution and Trump's first
year in office because he was very
honest and he said I fear that if we
don't impeach this president he will get
reelected they went after him for
there was this Russia collusion
narrative this began during the campaign
you had the government spying on the
Trump campaign and the DOJ and William
Barr have a lot to say about that we'll
get to it in a second then you had the
accusation of conspiracy with Russia you
had the Muller investigation after that
you had the investigation of impropriety
with his taxes then you're at the
impropriety accusations with stormy
Daniels maybe there was a little
impropriety there but certainly nothing
impeachable then you had the accusations
about Ukraine which is where we got this
whole impeachment inquiry from and they
all failed they all failed they were
trying to set the stage look if they
could have impeached Trump for Russia
three years ago they would have done it
but the Moller investigation didn't work
it didn't give Democrats the answers
they wanted so now they finally they
waited they kept trying they take their
shot on Ukraine and it flops so what is
Trump gonna do in response to this is he
gonna say woo good I'm glad glad that's
over that would have been really
terrible if I had to keep dealing with
that but now it's okay we'll get back to
a more moderate live-and-let-live let's
all be friends kumbaya moment no way
he's going after the people who tried to
remove him from office and it is a
beautiful thing we will get to that in a
second from his rally to a wonderful
explosive interview with Attorney
General William Barr but first speaking
of danger speaking of wild risk and
safety everyone knows about the risks of
driving drunk you know about that right
you could get in a crash people could
get hurt or killed so let's take a
little minute you all know about it
generally let's take a minute to look at
the statistics almost 29 people in the
United States die every single day in
alcohol impaired vehicle crashes that is
one person every 50 minutes even though
drunk driving fatalities have fallen by
a third in the last three decades which
is great news drunk driving crashes
still claimed more than 10,000 lives
each year many people are completely
unaware that driving while high can be
just as dangerous in 2015 42% of drivers
killed in crashes tested positive for
drugs 42
percent not so harmless after all isn't
from 2007 to 2015
marijuana use among drivers killed in
crashes doubled the truth is that
driving well high is deadly so stop
kidding yourself if you were impaired
from alcohol or drugs don't get behind
the wheel if you feel different you
drive different you drive high you get a
DUI drive sober where you get pulled
over I have a lot of friends I
especially when I was in college I'd
have friends who they would never get in
a car when they were drunk alright they
at least knew well enough not to do that
but then they they'd smoke a joint
they'd be high and they'd say oh no it's
fine for me to drive what are you
talking about you're just as impaired
the numbers bear that out
drive high get a DUI drive sober or get
pulled over all right back to trump
speaking of how high I feel not from
drugs not from things that impaired you
but from this excellent news that we've
been receiving today the impeachment
thing flopped right so President Trump
now is going on the offense the
Democrats took their shot they missed
and so now President Trump is going
after them not just the Democrats who
are trying to beat him for president not
just the Democrats trying to impeach him
but the Democrats also who attempted to
subvert the 2016 election overturn the
election use the state the FBI to DOJ
and the bureaucracy to oust President
Trump from office he begins this he
begins this this rally that he had last
night in Hershey Pennsylvania by summing
up the endless investigations and
impeachment enquiries and attempts to
overturn the election he does it by
reenacting his imagined scenes between
Lisa Paige and Peter struck they were
those two lovers at the FBI who kept
texting with one another about how they
were gonna stop him from becoming
president and how they were gonna
overturn the election President Trump in
his typically unsubtle way reenacted
this for his audience and for the
American people and they have to hear it
Peter struck
and his lover Lisa Paige
remember Lisa I love you so much Lisa
please Lisa Lisa I've never loved anyone
like you we won't allow this to happen
to our party Lisa please some of you
love me Liz I love you Peter I love you
I love you like I've never loved anyone
and if for any reason if for any reason
she loses even though she's a stone cold
corrupt person if for any reason she
loses Peter we've got to have an
insurance policy we have to do it
because we're gonna go and that's what's
been happening for the last two and a
half years okay some of the pearl clutch
errs object to this kind of behavior
they say it's below the dignity of the
president sure I agree I agree it's
below the dignity of the President Trump
is dealing with people who are not only
undermining the dignity of the FBI
supposedly neutral supposedly
nonpartisan supposedly above it all law
enforcement institution but they're
subverting our self-government so the
what you see the way Trump does this if
Trump had just gone out there and said
at a rally these FBI agents were acting
in a corrupt fashion and they were
trying to remove me from office and they
were behaving in a partisan way even
though there's not supposed to be
partisan and they were saying that they
wanted to have an insurance policy in
case I got elected no one would care no
I wouldn't be playing this clip you
wouldn't have heard it no one would see
it on Twitter so what Trump does because
he's our greatest showbiz president
certainly since Ronald Reagan if not
ever is he gives you a little spice
right sex sells so he goes and he frames
that is part of this adulterous affair
that we know happen because it's in the
text messages and then he in in the
midst of all that candy in the midst of
all that chocolate and sugar
he gets the medicine down and the
medicine is they were texting about an
insurance policy if Trump won an
insurance policy so he's saying the
American people vote one way but then
the FBI is going to undermine that
that's the implication of what they said
and so he's getting that in there he's
reminding you
myself had forgotten I remembered some
of the texts we can't let him win no no
no we won't happen we'll stop him I
forgot about the insurance policy that's
that's not good
that doesn't sound great that sounds
corrupt that sounds like a threat to our
self-government so he reminds you of
that and then lest you missed the point
he says it straight on he says the FBI
spied on his campaign and they ruined a
lot of good lives these folks they spied
on our campaign okay they spy
never happened before in the history of
our country
and we're really wise to it we're wise
to it the Inspector General found that
the FBI spying application contains 17
errors and omissions commonly known as
lies and deceit when the FBI and you
have great people in the FBI but not at
leadership you have not good people in
leadership you haven't had but they hit
it so that nobody could see it so they
could keep it going on thinking they
were going to hurt us politically but
now we're stronger politically than we
were ever before and the FBI also sent
multiple undercover human spies to
surveil and record people associated
with our campaign look how they've hurt
people they've destroyed the lives of
people that were great people that is
still great people their lives have been
destroyed by scum okay by scum Trump
does a lot in this statement he reminds
people that the FBI spied the way that
the press is spinning the inspector
general report is trying to convince you
that the FBI did nothing wrong okay
there were 17 glaring errors and
omissions on the FISA applications that
then allowed the son warranted spying
but really it was just a big mistake it
was a big misunderstanding no political
motivation here even though the Attorney
General William bar disagrees with that
we'll get to it in a second but it's no
big deal nothing to see here look away
and what Trump is saying is no that's
not true he then goes on to make an
important distinction he says there are
a lot of good people in the FBI but the
leadership was crooked here absolutely
true an important political point to
make is there are a lot of great people
in the FBI a lot of great people in law
enforcement but those political
appointees who were running the show a
lot of them were very corrupt and then
he shows he shows maybe the defining
characteristic of Trump's political
career and and his career in the media
he says they tried to get us they tried
to hurt us
and now we are stronger than we ever
were before what Trump is showing here
is that he has a quality that you might
call antifragility this is comes from a
book by Nicholas Taleb anti fragile
Trump is sort of politically anti
fragile what do I mean by that I mean
some people are fragile right so when if
you if you hit some people politically
if you knock them if you expose some
scandal if you go after them if you try
to make them unpopular or make them seem
corrupt or something it hurts them and
the more you do it it hurts them and if
you do it enough their career is over
some political candidates are durable
they're really hard so it's just a lot
harder to hit them with the scandal
right it might weaken them a little bit
but they're they're pretty durable so
you you throw a scandal at them and they
still survive the Clintons are kind of
like this right youth right it makes
them look corrupt it makes them look
kind of sleazy it does diminish their
support over time but you know they're
they can endure and then there's the
quality of being anti fragile being anti
fragile is when the more you hit
somebody the stronger they get that's
the quality that Trump has and it's by
virtue of I don't know being in the
public eye for 40 years as an
entertainer as a larger-than-life
cartoon figure as a casino mogul as a
real estate mogul as a politician who
wins the biggest office in the world the
first time he runs the more you attack
Trump and the more he survives the
stronger he gets it's an amazing quality
to have it's it's such a strong quality
that for instance now in the whole
impeachment inquiry they did reveal
something that maybe some people would
be uncomfortable with I think a lot of
people would admit that which is that
Trump is wheeling and dealing like he's
a New York real estate guy from the Oval
Office
rather than being this perfectly
detached statesman like figure right he
calls up Ukraine and he says hey Ukraine
perfectly legitimately I think by the
way he says there was a lot of
corruption oh look
like in the Obama administration you
want to look into that looks like you
guys had some pretty crooked deals in
the Obama administration I want you to
look into that right perfectly
legitimate but still it's a little that
you can't get him for it anymore because
the left has gone after Trump so many
times that every time they shoot and
miss he gets stronger he gets bigger
his numbers go up his base widens now if
you look at the polling in the swing
states after impeachment he's beating
every single Democrat running against
him before impeachment a number of
Democrats were beating Trump in
head-to-head polls now completely the
opposite that is a very valuable
characteristic when it comes to politics
and it's not just Trump saying you don't
just need to take Trump's word for it
the Attorney General William Bar is
backing up pretty much everything Trump
is saying about the FBI about the
Russian investigation and he's doubling
down on Trump's promise to go after the
people who tried to subvert the election
we will get to William Boras excellent
interview in a second
first did you know that The Daily wire
store is on Amazon you can go right now
as you do your Christmas shopping you
can head on over there from our classic
facts don't care about your feelings
shirts which is 15% off right now by the
way you're very popular maybe my
favorite the zero bark 30 shirt even
this very shirt cancel cancel culture
which I'm wearing right now myself you
can get all of it and now you can get
our brand new Santa Trump's hoax hoax
hoax Merry Christmas you will find
plenty of goodies there to make this the
best gift-giving season ever and if you
buy this week your order will arrive
just in time for Christmas so head on
over to the daily wire come and check
out our amazon store and let this
shopping begin all right let's get to
William Bar well Trump was putting on
this huge show this whole huge circus in
Pennsylvania
William bar was giving a very sober very
direct interview on NBC News and he was
responding to the IG investigation and
the IG report and he was also talking
about the next criminal investigation to
pick up where the IG report
left off he begins by absolutely
hammering the Obama administration for
their handling of the Trump campaign and
for their spine well I think I think
probably from a civil liberty standpoint
the greatest danger to our free system
is that the incumbent government used
the apparatus of the state principally
the law enforcement agencies and the
intelligence agencies both to spy on
political opponents but also to use them
in a way that could affect the outcome
of the election as far as I'm aware this
is the first time in history that this
has been done to a presidential campaign
the use of these counterintelligence
techniques against a presidential
campaign and we have to remember that in
today's world presidential campaigns are
frequently in contact with foreign
persons and indeed in most campaigns
there are signs of illegal foreign money
coming in and we don't automatically
assume that the campaigns are nefarious
and traitors and acting and league with
foreign powers there has to be some
basis before we use these very potent
powers in our core First Amendment
activity and here I felt this was very
flimsy I love this guy he reminds me in
his effect of Antonin Scalia he's very
intelligent he looks a little bit like
Scalia he speaks like Scalia very
measured at very precise even down to
his use of the word flimsy and what does
he say there in his very moderate way he
says the Obama administration spied they
acted inappropriately this is a major
threat to our system of government they
violated civil liberties they acted in
an unprecedented way in our history and
we are going to get to the bottom of it
and he doesn't even just leave it there
he also went after the press before I go
into a couple of other questions let me
just sort of button this up I think a
lot of people will hear what you're
saying here and think well that's just
bill barr defending
your concern about the FBI's
investigation is what civil libertarian
I think our nation was turned on its
head for three years I think based on a
completely bogus narrative that was
largely flan fanned and hyped by an
irresponsible press and I think that
there were gross abuses of FISA an
inexplicable behavior that is
intolerable in the FBI and the Attorney
General's primary responsibility is to
protect against the abuse of the law
enforcement and intelligence apparatus
and make sure that it doesn't play an
improper role in our political life
that's my responsibility and I'm gonna
carry it out that's right he's telling
the press to their face on NBC News that
an irresponsible press spread this
ridiculous hoax this guy has cool uni of
steel then he comes out and he says
there were gross inexplicable
intolerable abuses of the FISA process
not errors not whoopsie-daisy a little
mistake okay no big deal no harm no foul
he's saying abuses now you might ask
doesn't that contradict the IG report I
thought NBC News told me the very
dishonest mainstream media told me that
the IG report found that there was no
improper motivation there were no no no
furious plots it was just all a big
misunderstanding doesn't bar contradict
the IG report sort of but not really and
he explains how for both the press and
through the press for the American
people
so the Inspector General says he found
no evidence to indicate that the FBI's
decision to start this investigation was
based on a political bias do you agree
well what do you actually I think have
to understand what the I G's methodology
is and I think it's the appropriate
methodology for an Inspector General
he starts with limited information he
can only talk to people who were
essentially there as employee
and he's limited to the information
generally in the FBI but his approach is
to say if I get a explanation from the
people I'm investigating that is not
unreasonable on its face then I will
accept it as long as there's not
contradictory testimonial or documentary
evidence in other words it's a very
deferential standard and all he said is
people gave me an explanation and I
didn't find anything to contradict it so
I don't have a basis for saying that
there was improper motive but he hasn't
decided the issue of improper motive
this is the key point here because I
think it's confusing even for
conservatives they say hold on a second
we have these two investigations now
going on into the origin of the original
rush investigation you have the IG
investigation then you have this guy
John Durham the prosecutor that William
bar appointed to look into it how come
if the IG says basically it's all ok how
come there's still this John Durham
investigation and what Barr explains is
the IG investigation has a very
deferential standard there the the task
of the IG is not to get to the bottom of
the motivations and Grille people the
task of the IG is to get a story if the
story is not really contradicted then
there's no reason to disbelieve it it's
a very deferential standard and you hear
the implicit threat in his voice he says
yeah the IG had a very deferential
standard not much reason to get to the
truth but luckily we have a criminal
investigation going on as well luckily
we've got somebody on the case whose job
it is to get to the bottom of it whose
job it is to figure out the motivations
the IG may have said we have no evidence
to believe that there were political
motivations but John Durham and Bill
Barr go in there and they say yeah I
don't think we're gonna leave it at that
I'm pretty sure you come for the King
you best not miss I'm pretty sure we're
gonna get to the bottom of it so how are
they going to do it they're going to
engage in a full-on criminal
investigation and billboard gives us a
little preview of it I think we have to
wait until the investigation the full
investigation is done and that's the
fundamental
distinction between what Durham is doing
and what the IG is doing Durham is not
limited to the FBI he can talk to other
agencies he can compel people to testify
one of the the problems in the IDS
investigation I think he would agree is
that Comey refused to sign back up for
his security clearance and therefore
couldn't be questioned about classified
matters so someone like someone like
Durham can compel testimony he can talk
to a whole range of people private
parties fallen governments and so forth
and I think that is the point at which a
decision has to be made about
motivations listen to that the the
Inspector General can't compel witnesses
right the Inspector General just goes
makes his report okay here you go it all
checks out this criminal investigation
here can compel witnesses so who are
they gonna make testify who are they
gonna make give give some testimony I
don't know maybe maybe some of those
shady characters the trunk was making
fun of from the FBI maybe they're gonna
maybe they're gonna get James call me to
talk on the record I don't know maybe
they're going to try to get to the
bottom of all of that it's it's this
implicit threat and it's a perfectly
legitimate threat it's a threat that I
strongly support from William Barr who
says this ain't over you think that you
can use the mechanisms of the press you
think you can use the mechanisms of the
state even to try to subvert justice
here
Veon not me you remember when Bill Barr
was appointed he said look I've already
served as attorney general I've been
around this town a very long time and
this is gonna be a very messy situation
here a lot of people would shy away from
this job because it would ruin their
careers if their young ambitious
attorneys and prosecutors me
I've already had my career I got nothing
to lose here I am only interested in
getting the truth and I think that we're
about to see that he even shows he even
hints that not just for the people who
acted inappropriately but for the left
generally who relied on those bad actors
there's some bad news on the horizon
what questions will John Durham address
that the IG didn't
well Durham is is looking at the whole
waterfront he is looking at the issue of
how it got started he's looking at
whether or not the narrative of Trump
being involved in the Russian
interference actually preceded July and
was in fact the precipitating trigger
for the investigation
he's also looking at the conduct of the
investigation there are some things that
were done in the investigation that are
not included in Horowitz's report and
he's looking at those things but also a
few weeks ago I told him that he should
spend just as much attention on the
post-election period and I did that
because of some of the stuff that
Horowitz is uncovered which to me is an
explicit such applicable well what I
said is their case collapsed after the
election and they never told the court
and they kept on getting renewals on
these applications they those documents
falsified in order to get these renewals
there was all kinds of withholding of
information from the court and the
question really is what was the agenda
after the election that kept them
pressing ahead after their case
collapsed this is the president of the
United States fair enough totally
measured look you made a mistake on the
initial investigation that's fine but
hey hold on a second guys how come after
your case collapsed you kept trying to
get him how come after the election you
kept trying to subvert the election how
come for two and a half three years you
kept up this charade that part's not
explained in the IG report but maybe
we're gonna get to the bottom of that by
the way by the way this excellent
aggressive approach from all fronts the
cultural front the political front and
the bureaucratic front this is not just
a matter of domestic politics that the
Trump administration is doing this even
overseas there is great news that came
out just last night about US trade us
sovereignty and specifically the World
Trade Organization very few people are
courting on it because it's a move that
trump has made in accordance with
actually a fairly long-standing American
tradition and it's cracking up the
leftist utopian internationalist plans
and it is a big major win for the United
States for the economy and for
self-government we'll get to that in a
second we will get to why a Methodist
Church is putting Jesus and Mary and
Joseph in cages we will get to the word
of the year and we will get to the
dumbest article on the internet today as
always from our friends at The New York
Times but first listen up I am gonna
save you time and money this Christmas
season that's all I've been doing for
you the perfect gift for your loved ones
what is it is it I don't know some new
mug no is it some candle no it's a daily
wire gift subscription from now until
January 1st all insider plus gift
memberships will be 25% off that means
your loved one will get all the
fantastic perks plus the majestic the
lovely the beautiful leftist ears tumblr
and you will get the savings that's the
best part of all go to daily wire.com
slash gift to get your 25% off that's
daily wired.com slash gift to get your
25% off 25% of all insider plus gift
memberships this Christmas season then
you will give them a gift that they will
thank you for all year long and the
leftist tears just they just come for
free
that's just gratuitous on top that's a
little bonus head on over to daily
wire.com we'll be right back with a lot
more
great news coming out of the World Trade
Organization I think that's the first
time that statement has ever been
uttered in the history of the world at
midnight last night the Trump
administration got it's sneaky wish it
was it's been doing this sort of
surreptitiously for a while now it has
nullified the power of the WTO the World
Trade Organization
what is the WTO it's an organization
that was founded in 1995 to facilitate
free trade fine idea and theory right no
no huge objections necessarily in theory
except that once the United States
agreed to allow countries like China for
instance to enter the World Trade
Organization about 20 years ago all of a
sudden things got very unbalanced
because you had these major major world
powers like China getting the
protections in the World Trade
Organization of developing nations and
yet they were they're extremely wealthy
nations and they used it to their
massive advantage they were also
violating a lot of WTO treaties they
were and arrangements they were
illegally subsidizing their steel and
aluminum they were stealing our
intellectual property they were forcing
us to do business with crooked banks in
China these were all extra little taxes
and fees that were added on top of doing
business they were not behaving as
serious partners and yet we were bound
by the WTO regulations because if we
ever tried to fight back we would be
found in violation of the WTO the WTO a
sort of I guess a hopeful idea from the
90s that just hasn't worked out to our
benefit in recent years the way that the
Trump administration nullified the WTO
is it has blocked new appointments to
the appellate bodies to the appeals
court of the World Trade Organization
which means that the terms of two of the
last three judges on the WTO expired at
midnight now it's it's worth pointing
out here this isn't just Trump who's
done this president george w bush
started this process of not appointing
new judges and this continued under
Barack Obama to his credit and it
finally reached the climax under
President Trump
this is excellent news it's a big win
for sovereignty it's a big win for
self-government now if I guess in theory
the WTO is supposed to facilitate trade
reduce tariffs reduce barriers to trade
and we'll all be kumbaya in this
wonderful easy efficient marketplace all
around the world okay it doesn't really
work out that way by the way but even if
it did we're seeing this as part of a
larger debate right now which is between
total efficient technocratic
international bureaucracy and
sovereignty self government what do you
want you get to pick one what do you
want what matters more to you to me it's
pretty clear I want self-government I
want to have a say over our own national
destiny I want to defend our
Constitution
I want to engage in trade as a country
that benefits us and not surrender that
power to some international organization
that deals with us at times unfairly
maybe that means that trade will be a
little tougher in the short term maybe
that's a price I'm willing to pay the
destiny of man is not measured by
material computations we're spirits not
animals we have a constitution and we
have self-government that's another big
win for Trump it just shows this
aggressiveness even not just on the
domestic front but on the international
front we've wanted that for a long time
so that raises the question of
impeachment how are we gonna deal with
the trial in the Senate right now CNN is
reporting so you know take it with a
grain of salt but CNN is reporting that
there's a disagreement here Mitch
McConnell Senate majority leader wants
impeachment to be over with quickly he
wants this trial to goes to trial and
then they acquit him and that's it and
you can move right along now according
to CNN that's not what President Trump
wants president Trump wants to drag this
out he wants it to be a show he wants
this to be a spectacle he wants people
to come testify like Adam Schiff and
Hunter Biden Trump wants exactly what I
advocated for yesterday on the show and
Trump is right and Mitch McConnell is
wrong I love cocaine Mitch think he's a
great guy I understand why Mitch
McConnell might want to move this trial
along one so the Senate can get back to
it's business of pushing through a bunch
of conservative judges love that idea
that's great too because in politics
anything can happen so you don't want to
call say Joe Biden is a witness and then
all of a sudden he becomes very
sympathetic and it turns it on its head
okay I understand that
still impeachment helps the president
being aggressive helps the president
helps the Republican Party it helps
conservatives you don't need to call Joe
Biden I actually don't think you should
maybe Trump is even overreaching in
calling hunter Biden miss hunter Biden
is a Biden so maybe he could be
sympathetic you've got a call Adam
Schiff you got a call those awful
unlikable Democratic lawyers who were
preening on Capitol Hill last week you
got to drag all of them in front and
show just how weak a case the Democrats
have opposition to impeachment and
removals of 51% right now it'll be a 61%
by the time this thing is over if they
really drag it out and do it the right
way that's the show look when when your
opponents and politics come after you
and you mitt and they miss you that's a
wonderful feeling Winston Churchill
wrote about this I think it was in his
book my early life he said that he was
in a war zone and he felt a bullet go by
his head and it was the first time he
ever had the joy of being shot at and
missed that's good that's a relief but
then you've got to capitalize on that
it's kind of like blackjack blackjack
has almost even odds it's a pretty good
game to play but not if you just play
hand after hand without ever changing
your strategy you got to know in
blackjack when to split you got to know
when to double down you got to know when
to press your luck okay you've got to
know when to get really aggressive the
same thing is true in politics I think
Trump has that instinct he should follow
that instinct beyond politics or beyond
at least national politics and
presidential politics we have got a very
very stupid story coming out of a
Methodist Church the Clermont United
Methodist Church 30 miles east of my own
city of La they posted a photo on their
website of Jesus Mary and Joseph
in cages this is a real war on Christmas
the war on Christmas is becoming very
literal now they are actually
imprisoning the Holy Family not a great
idea why did they do it why do they put
Jesus Mary and Joseph in cages
topped with barbed wire because they
want to make the point that Jesus Mary
and Joseph
are refugees just like ms-13 gang
members coming up from El Salvador or
other people to they're just they're
just like refugees and if you oppose
totally open borders can you really call
yourself a Christian
certainly not according to the lead
priestess at this Methodist Church Karen
Clark Racine she's the lead pastor s and
she told the CNN affiliate their quote
we thought about the most refugee family
in the world the family of Jesus I don't
want to spend too long in this story I
just want to point out this is a a
leftist canard that comes up again and
again increasingly in every Christmas
every time the left wants to make some
stupid political point and it's simply
not true
it's both a stupid point to make and it
is literally not true so they say Jesus
was a refugee right he wasn't he's not
from Bethlehem he's not his family's not
from Bethlehem and yet he was born in
Bethlehem he was born in a manger or in
a cave you see he's a refugee no when
we're talking about refugees illegal
aliens fleeing their country crossing
the border we're talking about people
who are evading laws and entering a
country illegally Jesus was born in
Bethlehem because his mother and his
stepfather were going toward the civil
authority and obeying the civil
authority to register with the
government opposite situations well
Michael you might say what about when
Jesus Mary and Joseph fled to Egypt
certainly then he was a refugee still no
it is true
the Holy Family fled Herod fled this
Massacre that was about to happen and
fled to Egypt in fulfillment of
Scripture but when they fled to Egypt
they were not crossing borders illegally
they were not violating civil statutes
they were not acting as refugees the way
we talk about refugees from Latin
America or elsewhere today because Egypt
was part of the Roman Empire it'd be
like
fleeing from California to Texas
something that many people are doing
even today rather than fleeing from El
Salvador to the United States Egypt had
been part of the Roman Empire since 30
BC when Octavian defeated mark Mark
Antony and out stood Cleopatra from
Egypt so they are just it is a weak
slogan it's a dumb point that is also
based on historical ignorance and
illiteracy but it's a also product of
shadow shallow religion right we are in
Advent we are awaiting the long-expected
Jesus born to set his people free and
what the left wants to do is make some
cheap stupid political point about
immigration the birth of a savior in
Bethlehem the Incarnation the Nativity
of the divine logic of the universe to
set us free from our sin and redeem
mankind is much more interesting than
whatever stupid point you have to make
about the southern border it's much more
inspiring it tells us much more about
our humanity it's a far greater cause
for joy the left just doesn't understand
that they're so hysterically narrowly
obsessively Pope focused on these cheap
little political points they can't raise
their head up and look toward the
heavens or even look down into a cave
and Bethlehem at the Incarnation another
sad note on our culture today
merriam-webster dictionary has announced
the word of the year the word of the
year is they they huh that's a pretty
strange word of the year they has been
around for a long time why is it all of
a sudden becoming the word of the year
in 2019 it's because merriam-webster has
now redefined the word they not to refer
to multiple people not to be a plural
word but to be singular as in not he or
she but they they is a good person very
very sad
it shows you a
point about politics which is that all
these little minor issues the pronouns
the bathrooms things that we say are
trivial are actually supremely important
in politics how is the singular they
come about it's come about because of
gender ideology which has told us that
there's no such thing as men or women
that sex is different from gender the
gender now is a term that applies not to
grammar but to human beings that a man
can be a woman and a woman can be a man
simply by believing it so or simply by
really wishing it to be in a theology
that says we should pump little children
full of hormones if if a boy plays with
a Barbie doll or if a girl plays with a
toy truck or if their mother is just a
nut we should just pump them full of
hormones sterilize them stop them from
going through puberty that's what we
should do because really there's no such
thing as as biological sex that your
body has nothing to do with who you
really are with your identity this is
not true this is crazy this is an idea
that's only been around for about five
minutes and it's already affected our
popular language by removing even he and
she at this rate it will soon become
bigoted or it will be seen to be bigoted
to use gendered pronouns to say he or
she it will become politically correct
to only say they that is the move that's
underway right now language is the key
here the left always uses language to
change our culture and to achieve their
political ends why because language is
the stuff of our consciousness language
is how we think it's how we communicate
it's the only way that we can relate to
one another language is central to
politics
and they are fundamentally changing it
so for instance if they becomes not only
a singular pronoun but the preferred
singular pronoun then any objection that
a reasonable person might have to gender
ideology goes out the window because
gender ideology becomes baked into the
very premises of our culture and our
consciousness and our language very
stupid move from merriam-webster I have
I don't read merriam-webster I read the
Oxford English Dictionary but still not
not a good look
for the culture shows why we've got to
fight back every step of the way how can
you do it he's a very simple way and
it's very awkward and you don't like it
because it feels weird when you say it
when you refer to individuals say he or
she according to the OED he is the
gender-neutral singular pronoun he
doesn't necessarily mean a man but when
you're saying he and the general sense
can mean just an individual and when
you're talking about an individual who's
confused about his gender say Bruce
Jenner or somebody Caitlyn Jenner now
say Caitlyn Jenner that's perfectly fine
but refer to him as he not out of
cruelty Caitlyn Jenner seems like a nice
guy seems like I actually a fairly
reasonable guy as far as as far as not
only people confused about their gender
are concerned but as far as anybody in
Hollywood is concerned this actually got
some pretty decent politics but he is
not a woman he's admitted as much in his
own writing and in its own speaking you
need to insist upon that too because the
minute you lose that the minute you see
to the left the ability to define
ontological reality that you've seated
all of politics there's no reason in
even arguing about it anymore before we
go I gotta get to the dumbest Oracle on
the Internet today this comes from the
New York Times as it so often does and
it comes from Thomas Friedman the title
impeach Trump save America it's the only
thing to do if our country's democracy
is to survive this is a really really
dumb for really really dumb op-ed I
won't get to the whole thing because you
you can get the gist of it the first
couple paragraphs
he writes impeaching a president is the
most consequential thing our Congress
can do other than declaring war
so after great consideration I say
president Trump not only should be
impeached he must be impeached if dim
America's democracy is to remain intact
so if we're still going to Alette let
the people elect their own presidents we
need to subvert the will of the people
and ask their duly elected president
that's that's the premise here okay he
says why [ __ ] the facts here are not
in doubt Trump's allies and the media
and Congress have largely given up
disputing them Trump held up
rationally directed taxpayer funding to
strengthen Ukraine's military against
Russia until the new Ukrainian president
agreed to do what Trump called a favor
announced that Ukraine was investigating
Trump's most likely 2020 opponent Joe
Biden and his son who were involved with
the Ukrainian gas company first of all
the president conducts foreign policy
Thomas Friedman not the Congress we have
three co-equal branches of government
the executive is a co-equal branch it's
not subservient to the Congress second
of all
trumps forget about Trump's allies in
the media and Congress if he has any
talk about Trump's opponents Trump's
opponents are actually the ones who have
given up this stupid narrative that
you're trying to push because they
didn't charge him with bribery in the
impeachment if they actually thought
that he had committed an impeachable
offense they actually thought that he
was bribing Ukraine or extorting
extorting something out of Ukraine they
would have charged him with that in
impeachment after this three-year long
charade and after the impeachment
inquiry and hearings but they didn't do
it
because the point that you're saying is
incontrovertible not even the Democrats
in Congress believe anymore or they're
not willing to try to say with a
straight face third of all what you're
accusing Trump of doing Biden actually
did Biden actually did by his own
admission on video at the Council on
Foreign Relations he held up military
aid to Ukraine when there was a much
hotter war going on with Russia in
exchange for a political favor which is
that they stopped investigating his
crooked son who got six hundred thousand
dollars a year from a corrupt energy
company even though he's a total
derelict who just smokes crack a lot of
the time and has no qualifications
whatsoever
other than having the name bite him
while Joe was the sitting vice president
so the argument he's making here is
actually to kick Joe Biden out from
being the likely nominee of the
Democratic Party he's not making an
argument against Trump then Friedman
says generally speaking generally I love
this I love this look I have given this
great consideration we it's very serious
about impeachment but let's do it anyway
generally speaking I believe presidents
should be elected and removed by the
voters at the polls but when I hear
Trump's defenders scream impeachment
subverts the will of the people I say
really what the hell
do you think Trump was doing in Ukraine
he was subverting the will of the people
by scheming to use our tax dollars to
knock at his most feared opponent in the
coming election how is that so what what
are you talking about subverting the
will of the people Trump's the duly
elected president he conducts foreign
policy he was investigating crooked
deals that were going on in the past
administration perfectly legitimate its
Friedman is trying to use I would call
it Orwellian language to make reality
seem not only other than it is but the
opposite of what it is and then we get
to the money line if we say as
Republicans do that what Trump did is
not an impeachable offense we're telling
ourselves in every future president that
in contradiction of what the founders
wrote in the Constitution it is okay to
enlist a foreign power to tilt the
election your way Biden did that Biden
did that he first of all when Thomas
Friedman is talking about the
Constitution and how we have to abide by
what the founders and the Constitution
said I can't help but laugh but when
anybody in the New York Times does that
but what Joe Biden did was hold up
American military aid to Ukraine and
told Ukraine to fire a prosecutor who
was looking into his crooked sons
company okay that's what he did but
beyond that
lots of presidents have had contact in
presidential candidates have had contact
with foreign powers like for instance
the Hillary Clinton campaign in 2016
when they enlisted the services of
fusion GPS who hired a an ex foreign
intelligence operative named Christopher
steel to get dirt from other
intelligence operatives in Russia to
undermine our election and to a kick
Trump out of the general so that Hillary
could win that's what they actually did
she actually did that now I'm not even
begrudging her her ability to go dig up
Oppo research that's politics that's
happened for a long time but don't say
this is unprecedented we're not going to
have a legitimate president listen can
you imagine how much money candidates
would raise from Saudi Arabia or China
to tilt a future election their way
different countries get involved in
these elections Russia has been trying
to overturn our
for a hundred years by the way Barack
Obama just endorsed Justin Trudeau in
Canada was he interfering their election
was he subverting their elections Barack
Obama sent his campaign operatives over
to Israel to try to oust Bibi yet
Netanyahu was that shocking awful
terrible unconstitutional I don't think
so
Friedman says the integrity of our
elections would be shattered we would
never again have a legitimate president
be shattered we wouldn't have a
legitimate president and that's why we
need to use the power of impeachment for
the first time ever to remove a
president even though they couldn't
prove even the most they couldn't even
charge the most basic crime
bribery as an impeachable offense they
couldn't do that they got rid of that so
now they're charging with a vague abuse
of power and obstruction of Congress
it's the president's job to obstruct
Congress think they got nothing and
you're saying that unless we ask the
president for that we will never have a
legitimate president again I say the
opposite if we do as to president for
that we'll never have a legitimate
president again we will have
congressional supremacy and our founders
would be rolling over in their graves
luckily though luckily and I I really
can't this is a great blessing for our
country the Conservatives are fighting
back at the DOJ in the culture at the
White House at home and abroad we're not
taking it lying down anymore
a very important political maxim if you
come at the King you best not miss the
left missed now they're gonna face the
consequences that's our show on Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt Oh see
you tomorrow
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director Pavel why
douse key edited by Danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by Mike core Amina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera and our
production assistant is NIC Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there